Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速告诉大家一件现在正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. Without a merry entrance that this will be a year since the Aspiring Psychologist podcast was launched. So Christmas
这些原则都同样适用。Lisa本人还会直接提供丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的一小时辅导。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客开播一周年之际。所以，2021年圣诞
Eve 2021, I released three episodes, the first three episodes of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. So you've been able to listen to that for a year and many of you, it's been my great privilege to have you listen to me weekly and I've become part of your routines, which is lovely. So this episode I did record already and for some reason I could not get my mic to work properly. So I managed to record the whole episode thinking it was fine and it wasn't. So it might well be a little bit of a run through. I'm going to have to let that annoyance go, aren't I? Technology doesn't always work for us i couldn't get i couldn't get it to work on stream yard but i'm now getting it
前夕，我发布了《有抱负的心理学家》播客的前三集。你们已经听了一年了，很多人每周都听我的节目，这对我来说是莫大的荣幸，我也成为了你们日常生活的一部分，这真的很棒。所以这一集其实我已经录过了，但不知为何我的麦克风无法正常工作。我录完了整集，以为没问题，结果却不行。所以这可能只是一个简短的重录。我得放下这种烦躁，对吧？科技并不总是如我们所愿，我在Stream Yard上无法使用，但现在我正在
to work on zoom so i'm gonna do it in a slightly different way but hopefully you won't hear or see any changes when you actually do listen um or watch this on youtube or either listening via your usual podcast platform. So we are thinking about Christmas in mental health and what it means for us to be staff members or team members as well because it's very important both of those things. So if you are working in a mental health service, you might well be part of the squabbles for whose turn it is to work anyway, who worked last year. But there are also people in teams who like a chance to slip out for a day or two and go to the office and or the hospital, wherever you're working, and go when it's quieter and get some more work done or work their way through all of the stockpile of surplus foods that have been brought in for
在Zoom上尝试，所以我会用稍微不同的方式来做，希望当你在YouTube上观看或通过常规播客平台收听时，不会听到或看到任何变化。我们正在思考心理健康领域的圣诞节，以及作为员工或团队成员这对我们意味着什么，因为这两点都很重要。如果你在心理健康服务机构工作，你可能正参与关于谁该值班的争论，或者谁去年已经值过班了。但团队中也有一些人喜欢趁机溜走一两天，去办公室或医院，无论你在哪里工作，趁人少的时候去完成更多工作，或者处理掉那些为了
the share table. If you've never worked in a mental health team before, you will not perhaps be aware about the share table. And that can be triggering for people as well for people that have had eating issues in the past or currently suddenly that abundance of food and social expectations to eat it can be difficult as well and that is obviously around for our clients as well it's always worth having a conversation with them about how they navigate Christmas and the festive period and you know whether they how what they choose to eat and what other people around them eat and how that feels so I read something the other day that suggested that it's not uncommon for many of us to eat a surplus of calories to
共享餐桌而带来的过剩食物。如果你以前从未在心理健康团队工作过，你可能不知道“共享餐桌”。对于过去或现在有饮食问题的人来说，这可能会触发他们的心理负担。突然出现的丰富食物和社交上的进食期望可能会让人感到困难。显然，这对我们的客户来说也是如此。与他们讨论如何度过圣诞节和节日期间，以及他们选择吃什么、周围人吃什么以及对此的感受，总是很有意义的。我前几天读到一篇文章，建议我们许多人在圣诞节前夕及之后，
the tune of 500 or more per day in the run-up to Christmas and the days after it. And apparently that can add up to an increase of five pounds by the time the festive period has passed. And that might well be triggering for clients that you work with, or even having that level of food and abundance and pressure can be triggering. And there can feel like a social pressure to eat or to eat a decent portion. And this is especially problematic for people that might be anorexic or body dysmorphia issues or binge disorders or bulimia, for example. So just bear in mind that, you know, it might not just be a tub of roses, might not always be seen as a good thing in the services we work with and with the clients we support. So just have an awareness that that can be problematic for people. You know, might be you, might be someone you support, might be someone in your team. And, you know, many of us will be taking time off over Christmas but for people working in in prisons or secure services
每天多摄入500卡路里或更多。显然，这可能导致节日过后体重增加五磅。对于你服务的客户来说，这可能会触发他们的心理问题，甚至仅仅是面对这种食物的丰盛和压力也可能成为诱因。社交上存在进食或吃足量的压力。对于可能患有厌食症、身体畸形障碍、暴食症或贪食症的人来说，这尤其成问题。所以请记住，我们工作中的服务对象和客户可能并不总是觉得有一桶巧克力是件好事。要意识到这可能对某些人造成困扰。可能是你，可能是你支持的人，也可能是你团队中的某个人。而且，我们许多人会在圣诞节期间休假，但对于在监狱或安全服务机构工作的人，
other hospitals or you know in people's homes in community support roles they might well still be working over Christmas so if you are then thank you and well done. And hopefully you will be able to take some time off either in lieu or as annual leave at a later stage because time off is really important. And when we're working in difficult, challenging roles, sometimes it can feel tricky to take time off, especially if you're carrying a heavy load. So trying to access supervision before you finish for the year, either with your regular supervisor in person or over the phone or with a more experienced member of the team can be really advantageous so that you can just feel contained and able to relax over your break that you might have from work. And of course, not everybody celebrates Christmas, even if, you know, for all intents and purposes, they've been raised Christian, they might not choose to celebrate Christmas, especially if Christmas
或其他医院，或者在人们家中从事社区支持工作的人，他们可能在圣诞节期间仍需工作。所以如果你是这样，谢谢你，做得好。希望你以后能通过调休或年假补回来，因为休息真的很重要。当我们从事困难且具有挑战性的工作时，有时很难请假，尤其是如果你肩负重任的话。因此，在年底结束前尝试获得督导，无论是与你的常规督导面对面、通过电话，还是与团队中更有经验的成员交流，都是非常有益的，这样你就能感到被支持，并在工作之余真正放松下来。当然，并不是每个人都庆祝圣诞节，即使他们实际上是在基督教环境中长大的，他们也可能选择不庆祝，特别是如果圣诞节
has been a difficult or painful time for them in the past. So exploring with your clients and even with your staff teams about what Christmas and the festive break means for them in the past. So exploring with your clients and even with your staff teams about what Christmas and the festive break means for them can be really powerful and can help people feel seen. But trauma can show up at Christmas as well from Christmases gone by. And that might be because somebody has had a painful or difficult experience happen to them in previous Christmases, or maybe because they previously celebrated and shared Christmas with people who were very important to them. But, you know, either through grief and loss or just for reasons outside of their control, those people are no longer, that person is no longer in their lives. That can feel
在过去对他们来说是一段困难或痛苦的时光。因此，与你的客户甚至员工团队探讨圣诞节和节日假期对他们意味着什么，是非常有力的，能帮助人们感到被看见。创伤也可能在圣诞节期间因过去的圣诞节而显现。这可能是因为某人在之前的圣诞节经历过痛苦或困难，或者是因为他们曾经与对自己非常重要的人一起庆祝和分享圣诞节。但是，无论是通过悲伤和失去，还是仅仅因为超出他们控制的原因，那些人不再出现在他们的生活中。这可能会让人感到
very triggering indeed. So having a check in with people about what Christmases have been like in the past and what they might be imagined to be like can be really useful too. Bearing in mind that lots of services will be grinding to a halt over the festive period, including pharmacies and maybe even psychiatrists, it is important to make sure that your clients have enough medication to get them through until after all the bank holidays you know we have busy lives when we're trying to sort out Christmas gifts and you know the endless Christmas jumper days and things if we've got children in schools things can easily slip off the to-do list so just having an awareness maybe developing a little checklist for yourself to make sure you've had the conversation with each of the clients that you support
非常受触发。因此，与人们核实过去的圣诞节是什么样的，以及他们想象中会是什么样的，也非常有用。考虑到许多服务机构在节日期间会停摆，包括药房甚至可能是精神科医生，确保你的客户有足够的药物度过所有银行假日非常重要。我们忙于处理圣诞礼物，还有无休止的圣诞毛衣日之类的事情，如果我们有孩子在学校，这些事情很容易从待办事项清单中漏掉。所以要保持警惕，也许为你自己制定一个小清单，确保你已经与你支持的每一位客户进行了沟通，
about whether they have enough medication to get them through because of course it might be damaging for their mental health or for those they live with if they are not able to access all the medication that they need. And also on your checklist would be making sure that you've got updated risk and care plans in place for your clients. There will usually be a crisis or duty service available, but people are going to very much be more up to speed if they're able to read some recent documentation. And it's helpful as part of that risk planning to have, you know, a contingency plan for what a client does if they're feeling like they can't cope. So that's all useful stuff to consider with your clients ahead of any break. They might find it helpful to do some activity scheduling with you as well
关于他们是否有足够的药物度过假期，因为如果他们无法获得所需的药物，这可能会损害他们的心理健康或与他们同住的人的健康。此外，你的清单上还应包括确保你为客户制定了更新的风险和护理计划。通常会有危机或值班服务，但如果人们能够阅读最近的文档，他们会更了解情况。作为风险规划的一部分，有一个应急计划很有帮助，即如果客户感到无法应对时该怎么做。这些都是在假期前与客户考虑的有用事项。他们可能还会觉得与你一起进行活动安排很有帮助，
to keep them feeling like they've got more options available to them when their usual sources of support might not be available. Let's take a quick break here to listen to the sleigh bells for the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book. It's still time to order it ready for delivery for Christmas Day. And the same with the Clinical Psychologist Collective and the Grief Collective, if you might fancy popping that in your own stocking or someone that you care about too. And of course, if you're, you know, making your Santa wishlist, then maybe you might like some months in the Aspiring Psychologist membership too. So do bear that in mind too. It'd be so welcome and lovely to get to know you better in that space.
让他们在常规支持渠道不可用时，感到自己有更多的选择。让我们在这里休息一下，听听《有抱负的心理学家集体》一书的雪橇铃声。现在订购还来得及在圣诞节当天送达。同样，《临床心理学家集体》和《悲伤集体》也是如此，如果你想把它们放进你自己的圣诞袜或送给你关心的人。当然，如果你正在列你的圣诞愿望清单，也许你也会喜欢“有抱负的心理学家”会员资格的几个月。所以也请记住这一点。在这个空间里更好地了解你，将是非常受欢迎和令人愉快的。
Hope you enjoy the slow bells and I will speak to you in a moment. On the way to getting qualified So many tips and lessons to learn from So many things that you can try The Aspiring Psychologist Collective The Aspiring Psychologist Collective Welcome back. So this year, more than ever, there might be increased pressures on families and individuals because of the cost of living crisis. And of course, it might feel even more challenging to heat homes over the festive break. It might be worth checking in with your local community to see whether there are any warm space initiatives happening over the festive break, which is where
希望你喜欢这些铃声，我一会儿就回来。在获得资格的路上，有太多的技巧和经验教训可以学习，有太多的事情可以尝试。《有抱负的心理学家集体》，《有抱负的心理学家集体》。欢迎回来。所以今年，比以往任何时候都更甚，由于生活成本危机，家庭和个人可能面临更大的压力。当然，在节日期间为家庭供暖可能会感到更具挑战性。值得向你当地的社区查询一下，看看节日期间是否有任何“温暖空间”倡议，也就是
people are heating public spaces and offering cups of tea, maybe biscuits, some soup, things like that. And just reiterate with your clients, there's absolutely no shame in that and that they might actually benefit from that. And similarly, when I worked for Argos head office, there was the, yeah, on Christmas day, people were to be by themselves there was um a free christmas meal available and they used to pick people up and drop them off as well if they needed that so um there might well be services or support um systems near you that specifically support people who are lonely at christmas um or for you know for whatever reason are going to find it more challenging to be by themselves.
人们为公共空间供暖并提供茶、饼干、汤之类的东西。再次向你的客户重申，这绝对没有什么可羞耻的，他们实际上可能会从中受益。同样，当我为Argos总部工作时，在圣诞节那天，对于那些独自一人的人，有一个免费的圣诞餐，如果他们需要，他们还会接送他们。所以，你附近可能确实有专门支持圣诞节感到孤独的人，或者因为某种原因发现独自一人更具挑战性的人的服务或支持系统。
So, yeah, check that out. And similarly, you know, it might be that you might need to help pave the way for clients to be able to access food banks over the festive period. So having that conversation with people about whether they've got enough food for the festive break, especially given there's a couple of bank holidays where often supermarkets will be shut. With the shortest day of the year in the UK being the 21st of December, we might also notice that people are experiencing more symptoms of seasonal affective disorder. And so, you know, just holding that in mind,
所以，去查一下。同样，你可能需要帮助为客户铺平道路，让他们能够在节日期间获得食物银行的帮助。因此，与人们讨论他们是否有足够的食物度过节日假期，特别是考虑到有几个银行假日，超市通常会关门。随着英国一年中白天最短的一天是12月21日，我们可能还会注意到人们正在经历更多的季节性情感障碍症状。所以，记住这一点，
we can think about the advice of trying to get some daylight, perhaps by going for a stroll, sort of first thing in the morning when you wake up and the sun's coming up, and maybe thinking about getting, if you're working from home, getting, you know, daylight bulbs for any of the lamps that you might sit by for much of the day. But yeah, having a chat with your service users about how they notice their mood fluctuate throughout the year, especially in the colder months can be useful. And not everyone likes Christmas. Not everyone likes a Christmas party. You know, we are either extrovert, introvert, or I believe ambivert, which is somewhere in between, and we can do both. And yeah, it might
我们可以考虑建议尝试获取一些日光，也许在早上醒来太阳升起时去散散步，如果你在家工作，可以考虑为你大部分时间坐着的地方的灯换上日光灯泡。但是，与你的服务对象聊聊他们如何注意到自己的情绪在一年中波动，特别是在寒冷的月份，是有用的。并不是每个人都喜欢圣诞节。并不是每个人都喜欢圣诞派对。我们要么是外向者、内向者，或者我相信是中间的“双向性格者”，我们可以两者兼顾。而且，这可能
not be quite the social frivolity that you might find it or that others might find it. And so yeah, just know that if you don't want to go to the christmas party you don't have to go um and if you find it difficult or if your clients find it difficult or challenging to be around people who might not have been good people to them in the past we can empower them to to say no as well you get to choose they get to choose um especially if they're adults but um when it's difficult to be around people and you feel like you don't have control that can feel really triggering and really challenging so yeah I'm hoping that you have a nice festive break whatever you're up to time off when we're working in these demanding jobs can be so important and being able to yeah to clock off and know that you are feeling contained
不像你或其他人可能发现的那样充满社交乐趣。所以，要知道如果你不想去圣诞派对，你不必去。如果你觉得困难，或者如果你的客户觉得与过去可能对他们不好的人在一起感到困难或具有挑战性，我们也可以授权他们说不。你可以选择，他们也可以选择，特别是如果他们是成年人的话。但是，当与人相处很困难，而你觉得无法控制时，这可能会让人感到非常受触发和具有挑战性。所以，我希望你有一个愉快的节日假期，无论你在做什么。当我们从事这些要求苛刻的工作时，休息时间非常重要，能够下班并知道你感到被支持，
and like you've done everything that you potentially could do to try to ensure that the service and the people that you support within it are going to have the best possible time off from the service or from you if you are working over the festive break, then yeah, hoping you have some time off at a future time. But also there can be, you know, joyful times about working. I certainly have worked on Christmas morning when I was a home carer and very much felt privileged to be able to spread some warmth and cheer to people on Christmas morning. So yes, thank you for being part of my world. Thank you for the important work that you do. Sorry, this episode is slightly shorter. I had said it all already. And yeah,
并且觉得你已经尽了最大努力来确保服务机构和你支持的人在节日期间或你休假时能度过尽可能好的时光，那么，希望你在未来的某个时间能有假期。但工作中也可能有快乐的时光。我确实在圣诞节早晨工作过，当时我是一名家庭护理员，能够在那天早上为人们传播一些温暖和快乐，我感到非常荣幸。所以，谢谢你成为我世界的一部分。谢谢你所做的重要工作。抱歉，这一集稍微短了一点。我已经把该说的都说了。而且，
darned microphones, not sure what's going on. Hopefully it will sort itself out. Maybe it's tired after a year and it will sort itself out maybe it's tired after a year and it will sort itself out with some renewed vigor in the new year so yeah thank you for listening i've been part of my world and looking forward to catching up with you for our next episode of the aspiring psychologist podcast which will be coming to you from 6 a.m monday take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide Monday. Take care. Without a merry entrance My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book.
该死的麦克风，不知道出了什么问题。希望它能自己解决。也许它工作了一年累了，在新的一年里会恢复活力。所以，谢谢你的收听，成为我世界的一部分，期待在下一集《有抱负的心理学家》播客中与你相见，节目将于周一早上6点发布。保重。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。周一。保重。没有欢快的开场。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。
I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，这让我感到惊讶，而且没有完美的途径可以成为一名临床心理学家，这让我充满了信心，觉得我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。